[Musik]
grönlands atemberaubende landschaft doch
die eigentlichen schätze dieser
unendlich großen insel liegen für viele
unter eis und schnee edelsteine wieder
rote duc tho bis zum beispiel die länder
groß und würde gerne mit diesem reichtum
seiner heimat geld verdienen als erster
grönländer mit einer eigenen kleinen
söhne seit meiner kindheit habe ich
davon geträumt einen schatz auszugraben
weil sich dann hörte dass in südgrönland
uran abgebaut werden sollte wollte ich
zeigen dass es umweltfreundlichere
bodenschätze gibt zum beispiel solche
edelsteine in warmen friendly koran
seltene erden oder gold angelockt vom
schmelzenden eis wollen immer mehr
ausländische investoren von der
autonomen regierung der insel minen
lizenz einheimische in ried wie holten
ärgert dass die bodenschätze grönlands
bislang nur von ausländern ausgebeutet
werden mit der vergabe der ersten großen
minen lizenzen 2009 ging es los
dabei gibt es bis heute in grönland
keine öffentliche debatte darüber was
wir eigentlich und vor allem wie wir es
aus dem boden holen sollen müssen die
vielen neubauten in der hauptstadt nuuk
können nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen
fast jeder fünfte grönländer lebt
unterhalb der armutsgrenze
unternehmer olsen will darum dass die
gewinne aus den bodenschätzen im land
bleiben und das meinen auch viele seiner
landsleute
kurz wir sollten von unseren
bodenschätzen profitieren
es ist doch unser land liebt dich der
profit sollte uns gehören das machen
andere länder doch genauso wie sie genau
so wie hier vor zwei jahren gegen
grönländer immer wieder auf die straße
gegen die ausbeutung der grönländischen
bodenschätze durch großkonzerne
doch für den zuständigen minister gibt
es keine alternative zu den großen
investoren aus china australien oder den
usa
ein unternehmen muss über die notwendige
erfahrung und das wissen verfügen womit
einer schwierigen natur wie in grönland
zurecht zu kommen und es muss auch das
notwendige kapital haben um unsere
vorgaben erfüllen
diese haltung der regierung verbittert
ilunga großen zu hause entdeckte er auf
der karte des ministeriums dass
multinationalen konzernen erneut gebiete
für erkundungen zugesprochen worden sind
wie sollen wir gegen die ankommen wir
haben einfach nicht die mittel und das
geld um solche großen minen zu betreiben
doch auch um ihre beiden kinder willen
wollen holten und seine frau nicht
aufgeben die frage der bodenschätze sei
schließlich wichtig für die zukunft
grönland denn irgendwann einmal soll
grönland unabhängig sein
unsere kinder sollen es einfacher haben
als wir
sie soll in ihrem land selbst bestimmt
leben selbst darüber entscheiden was mit
den bodenschätzen und allem anderen
passiert ich wünsche mir dass sie später
in einer gesellschaft leben in der sie
glücklich sein können
auf dem weg zur eigenen kleinen mine
wilson nicht nach
mit einer lizenz in der tasche hofft er
spätestens im nächsten jahr loslegen zu
können
die inuit müssen uns mehr zutrauen sagte
weil wir so lange kolonialisiert worden
sind herrscht vor allem bei der älteren
generation immer noch die haltung vor
dass die regierung nur machen
herpel roten will das ändern und selbst
von den reichtümern seines landes
profitieren wenn auch nicht um jeden
preis
denn wenn zum klimawandel dem raubbau
kommt das weiß auch er könnte von
grönland atemberaubender schönheit
irgendwann nicht mehr viel übrig bleiben